when someone has the amount of money
that you have you start to learn you're
kind of forced to learn some financial
literacy right
because that's a lot of [ __ ] money
um your money to teach you what are some
of the lessons that having that much
wealth accumulated at such a young age
that you learned that you would try to
spread to other people because because
financial literacy is one of those
things that
you know unfortunately isn't taught in
schools enough well i learned that your
money will work harder than you
you know a lot of people try to work to
make money but you should let money work
for you
that's some real [ __ ]
and and basically i figured that out and
once i did that's when i would go buy a
million dollars worth of cocaine and
then i would pass it out to different
people
and then the next day they would all
bring me my money back because you ain't
standing on the corner selling your
[ __ ] self exactly
what were that's your money working for
you yeah i mean and i think that in in
terms of just what the wealthiest people
we know that's what they do oh
absolutely whether they have stocks that
go up and down whether they i mean [ __ ]
as simple as a vending machine you have
a vending machine that vending machine
you're not there the vending machine is
making your money working it's working
for you
yeah if you go out and buy bulldozer
that's your money working piece of
property rent it out there it is